[Applause]
never before has a World Cup host nation
had to wait so long for its tournament
to begin the 12-year build-up is almost
over for Qatar it's one that hasn't
always been easy
on the eve of kickoff the head of world
football went on the attack against
criticism of FIFA and the host country
and defended their record of making
progress on issues such as human rights
don't criticize Qatar don't criticize
the players don't criticize anyone
criticize FIFA criticize me if you want
because I'm responsible for everything
but let the people enjoy this world cup
Infantino try to redirect attention onto
the reason the World Cup has come to the
Middle East it's not too ideology is
playing against each other it's two
football teams playing against each
other
it's football it's football if we don't
have at least football to bring us
together if we listen to you all who are
criticizing who just want to divide
which world are we going to you want
another world war okay go ahead without
me without me
a tournament that began in Uruguay in
1930 is once again breaking new ground
the first for the Arab world the first
time so many fans will be in one place
[Applause]
and a first for qatar's national team
when Qatar won the bid to host this
tournament the team was ranked outside
the world's top 100. now they're at
number 50 and are the Asian Champions
and to give them extra hope or extra
pressure no host nation has ever lost
its Opening match at a World Cup that
opener is against Ecuador at albate
Stadium on Sunday yeah
it's a very important day for us a
historic moment a moment of happiness
for the players and staff it's an
extraordinary day like no other
the winner
to organize
the 222 FIFA World Cup is Qatar
having won the vote to host This World
Cup back in 2010 Qatar stepped into the
sporting Spotlight like never before
[Applause]
Kevin of the eight stadiums have sprung
up in a decade they've been a focal
point for the safety of Migrant workers
FIFA's president hopes they'll also be
emblematic of some of football's
greatest moments
now it's the world's best players who
are ready to take Center Stage as the
biggest sporting event in the middle
east's history finally begins
Paul Reese Al Jazeera Doha